Mr Ambassador I want to put to you some
allegations being made
by Russia against Britain by your
Security Council Chief Mr petrochev he's
claiming UK forces blew up the
nordstream pipelines he's claiming UK
forces helped carry out an attack on
Russian ships in the Black Sea
he is claiming British Security Services
are recruiting members of international
Terror organizations to fight in Ukraine
and he is claiming Ukraine is working
right now on a dirty bomb with Western
help where is the evidence for any of
that the evidences are on the
participation of British Special Forces
in preparation or for the action against
uh Sebastopol fleet has been delivered
to British Ambassador this morning and
to the military of Britain also this
year we've delivered the evidence to
over there yes our ambassador so why
don't you show the world
the evidence because these are very
serious allegations yes why don't you
see the world the evidence we perfectly
know about participation of British
specialists in training preparation and
execution of plans against the Russian
infrastructure and the Russian Fleet in
Black Sea and we know that it has been
done as I said we do have detailed uh
things which has been delivered I will
say that
let me fix it
it will come public pretty soon you will
provide evidence of British involvement
so in an attack on a Russian ship
exactly it will come public pretty soon
I guess perhaps today perhaps tomorrow
but we know that it is happening and it
is dangerous because it escalator the
situation it can bring us to the line of
uh I would say no return return is
always possible but anyway we should
avoid escalation and this is a warning
actually that Britain is too deep in
this conflict and of course it means
that it means a situation is becoming
more and more dangerous but Britain is
only involved in this conflict because
your country invaded a sovereign
independent state and is killing
thousands of civilians where's the
evidence then that Britain blew up these
pipelines uh oh I I didn't say that I uh
it is under investigation but I can say
that for two years uh but it is Special
Forces were training Ukrainian Special
Forces inachakov but that doesn't mean
they blew up the paper recurring them
procuring them and they also provided
them with underwater drones also
teaching them explosives but where's the
evidence for this why didn't you provide
the evidence for this it's very simple
if you've got the evidence
show it this all makes sense only if it
is a means to distract from Russia's
failing in this war
um to distract from Russians war crimes
the crimes against humanity and perhaps
to pave the way for an escalation that
is the only way these claims this is
your conclusion it is not my conclusion
it is just dangerous we are trying to to
point out that it might happen we are
not saying that Duty boom is is over
there it's going to explode but we
personally are aware that this type of
this preparation highly likely are
possible and we just want to attract
attention of people or to a security
Council especially especially for
biological weapon that some
investigation needed to be done we do
not want to distract attention it is we
are doing our military people are doing
the job over there so Vladimir Putin's
spokesman said there will be reprisals
for these things he says of course we
will think about further steps it cannot
be left like this what sort of reprisals
are you unless you're about military
diplomatic economic uh I'm not sure what
is a dissertation or that what do you
mean uh repressors on what subject if
you're talking about cooperation
underwater cooperation then we we
continue to study what what has happened
I don't know stream as well we know that
a studies has been done by Sweden and
Denmark they did not reveal uh what is
the origin of it and what has happened
study is now being said that the UK is
responsible for blowing up those
pipelines if you allow me to finish I
appreciate you your next question study
is continuing what has what kind of
explosion has happened underwater over
there it is too far is too difficult to
find out but as soon as we will find out
uh of course we will think about steps
where there is plenty of evidence is
that you are you are attacking civilian
infrastructure and energy infrastructure
in Ukraine because you've admitted it
the defense Ministry has admitted it why
are you plunging people in Ukraine Into
Darkness and why are you destroying the
water supply of Ukraine
these strikes which has been executed in
the recent years they mean uh to strike
command and control communication system
and Logistics mostly and it energy
supplies as well it is it has to be
prevented uh the movement of troops by
railway from region to region I will
remind you that Americans in this
situation they bump the bridges on
Daniel in 1999 in Serbia and destroyed
all bridges we are not doing this but
that that is a different thing to
consigning families in residential areas
to a winter without power and without
water what did what are you trying to do
to freeze these civilians to death what
are you trying to do this is also wrong
wrong perception because it is a
Ukrainian infrastructure as they are
admitting is destroyed a bit now by 30
percent they can reconstructed by it it
is the energy infrastructure does exist
the fact that they can rebuild it
doesn't make it right you know does it
but these people they're a long power
Cuts they're a long power outages uh yes
but it is it is still reconstructable
our cause was to prevent uh as I said uh
and to damage the military
infrastructure in the first place and it
has been done isn't the truth that you
are not waging a successful war against
the Ukrainian military so you are now
Waging War on Ukrainian civilians for
about months in the half ukrainians
cannot gain a single piece of terrain
over there they're sitting on their own
places without uh or without further
progressing and all of that is wrong but
why are you also Waging War then on the
poorest in the world by
not allowing ready supplies of grain to
reach these people by threatening to
withdraw altogether from the grain
agreement why are you bringing the
poorest people in the world into this we
continue no the delivery we as we
facilitate delivery of Ukrainian green
right at the same time at the same time
we have plenty of green ourselves and we
are trying to deliver it to the uh to
Africa to a number of countries over
there but we are still not allowed to do
this by sanctions will you renew the
grain shipment deal which currently
expires in I think two or three weeks
time it is expired at school on the 19th
of November I cannot guarantee because
of the second part of the deal about
delivery of the Russian green and we
suggest uh part of it will be free free
of charge it will still this second part
of deal is not being fulfilled the
Kremlin said last night that the world's
five nuclear powers are on the brink of
direct armed conflict do you think that
is true
the nuclear war cannot cannot be won and
it should never be fought and we stick
strongly to this statement we will not
use a nuclear weapon because it is
designed for different purposes you will
not use a nuclear Warner what about a
tactical nuclear weapon in Ukraine no it
is you well now the world has good every
assurances that Russia is not going to
use technical nuclear weapon in
Ukrainian conflict what about
negotiations is there a chance that
there could be negotiation to end this
yes I'm sure that it is always a good
chance to have a good negotiations with
a good will and a realistic
understanding of the situation so what
would be the minimum that Russia would
want in those negotiations do you still
want to keep your troops
in Ukraine you're asking me questions
which I cannot answer because a
negotiations are not in view and what
will be our position uh and Ukrainian
position at these negotiations it is
hard to predict of course do you think
President Putin wants a way out of this
war now I think yes
I'm sure that we need a
uh and a certain outcome negotiated
outcome and we are not hiding away from
the negotiations we just want Ukrainian
side but ukrainians has now prohibited
by law that they're going to participate
in negotiations you say President Putin
wants to finish this war now
um either it is now or not now I cannot
say I cannot say it for him he is the
Supreme Commander over there he's
president of our country and he is as we
have said but would that require in your
view we still does that require Russian
Russian forces to stay in Ukraine if we
will need to protect the Russian
population which is populating all this
area right now of course we will need
that Russian troops to stay over the
year the ukrainians won't accept that
because it is their sovereign country
what happens is just a prolonged war is
it is a long way I can imagine yes
better than a bad piece for you you know
I can imagine that Ukraine simply is
going to lose more and more terrain and
more and more resources that it has been
the potential isn't comparable of two
countries and there is no way that
Ukraine can win so you don't want to
control the whole of
no we're helping all the Russian people
that are living over there Russian and
russian-speaking people who were
deprived of their own rights who were
discriminated and killed over there
Mr Ambassador thank you very much thank
you very much